wer denkt schon an all die Frauen und
Männer die sich heute um einen der 435
Sitze im
US-Repräsentantenhaus bewerben oder an
jene die in den Senat gewählt werden
wollen wohl die allermeisten denken nur
an das Eine oder genauer an den einen an
Donald Trump Trump vorübergehend
politrentner wohnhaft derzeit noch mal
alago Florida Traum der einen Albtraum
der anderen dass der Vorgänger von
President byten auch des Nachfolger
werden könnte darüber wird heute
möglicherweise vorentschieden und nicht
nur ein Urteil über Corona Ukraine Hilfe
und Inflation gefällt es könnte eine
Wahlnacht werden zwischen disaster
und Triumph
US-Kongresswahlen Rückenwind für Trump
jetzt in Phoenix Runde
wir wissen dass unsere Demokratie in
Gefahr ist und wir wissen dass dies der
Moment ist sie zu verteidigen denkt
daran dass die Macht in Amerika immer in
den Händen der Menschen liegt
wenn ihr die Zerstörung unseres Landes
stoppen und den amerikanischen Traum
retten wollt dann müsst ihr in einer
riesigen roten Welle abstimmen
ja die beiden die gar nicht zur Wahl
stehen aber um die sich alles dreht Joe
Biden und Donald Trump und damit
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio ist Claudia buckmayer
ehemalige langjährige Stute Leiterin der
ARD in Washington jetzt hier im ARD
Hauptstadtstudio in Berlin tätig und sie
haben ein Buch geschrieben mit dem Titel
wer rettet Amerika aus Amerika genauer
gesagt aus Washington zugeschaltet
Annika Brockschmidt Historikerin
Journalistin und Buchautorin ihr Buch
dass sie veröffentlicht haben trägt den
Titel Amerikas Gotteskrieger wie die
religiöse Rechte die Demokratie
gefährdet das sind ja eine der
hauptunterstützungsgruppen von Donald
Trump aus Geiger ist bei uns von der
Welt Leiter des Ressorts Außenpolitik
und Tyson Barker ist von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik die
GAP und dort
US-Experte Frau bokenmeier
die demokratiestunde auf dem Wahlzettel
so Joe beiden auch bei dieser
Veranstaltung war ja der griffige Satz
den er von sich gegeben hat die steht
auf dem Wahlzettel in einem Land dass
ich seit
1776 Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
verschieben hat ist das übertrieben
diese Bemerkung mit dem Wahlzettel auf
dem die Demokratie steht also ich
persönlich finde sie nicht übertrieben
auch wenn man das gleichzeitig Angst
macht wenn ich das so sage und ich es
lieber hätte wenn es nicht so wäre aber
ich denke in einem Land in dem eine Wahl
die vor zwei Jahren stattgefunden hat
noch von vielen Menschen nach wie vor
nicht anerkannt war deren Rechtmäßigkeit
nicht anerkannt wird hatten wirkliches
Problem mit dem Vertrauen in die
Demokratie mit dem Vertrauen in das
Wahlsystem mit all dem was eigentlich
die Basis von dem ganzen ausmacht Frau
Brockschmidt Demokratie Ja oder Nein
Schicksalswahl ist das auch für das auch
Themen oder
wie man so schön sagt Frames die die
Amerikaner umtreiben
ja ich denke auf jeden Fall also wir
sehen ja es geht um wahnsinnig viel also
eine Mehrheit der republikanischen
Kandidaten die jetzt zur Wahl stehen
laut der Washington Post und das ganze
291 von ihnen die behaupten eben dass
die letzte Wahl von der Demokraten
gestohlen worden sei Teile von denen
haben auch schon angekündigt dass sie
2024 nur ein republikanischen Wahlsieg
akzeptieren werden das heißt wir haben
es hier wirklich mit einer
republikanischen Partei zu tun die sich
allein in den letzten zwei Jahren sehr
radikalisiert hat und Demokraten müssen
eben versuchen dagegen anzukämpfen
haben die Demokraten eigentlich ihre
Erwartungen schon so weit runter
gestaubt dass sie das Repräsentanten aus
verloren gegeben haben und jetzt hoffen
diese knappe Senatsmehrheit noch zu
retten also ich glaube für die
Demokraten die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt
die denken dass es gibt viele neue
Wähler viele
Ungewissheiten viele unknown unknowns
sozusagen dass man nicht genau wissen
könnte aber immerhin wenn man die
Umfragen anschaut ist die
höchstwahrscheinlichkeit des
Abgeordnetenhaus verloren geht und das
wird natürlich die Temperatur in
Washington wesentlich verändern
als lame duck wie man das so schön sagt
als lahme Ente das könnte das Ergebnis
der Wahl ja sein oder ist es
wahrscheinlich auch wenn er vor allen
Dingen oder wenn die Demokraten beide
Häuser verlieren werden was bedeutet
eigentlich eine lahme Ente Joe Biden für
den Westen für Europa und war auch für
Deutschland es bedeutet
dasselbe was eigentlich jede
US-Regierung seit vielen Jahren schon
bedeutet nämlich dass man viel stärker
darauf achten muss was Deutschland und
Europa selbst für seine Sicherheit und
für seine Rolle in der Welt machen kann
und der Donald Trump hat man das ja
genau gesehen und damals hat er Angela
Merkel zum Beispiel auch gesagt europa
muss viel mehr sein Schicksal in die
Hand nehmen in ihrer damaligen Bierzelt
Rede
passiert es danach quasi nichts und
jetzt hatten wir zwei Jahre Joe Biden
der sich als extremer Transatlantiker
entpuppt hat muss man sagen und hinter
dem wir uns mehr oder weniger versteckt
haben das wird er nicht mehr möglich
sein Bruder vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz zu Erklärung der Worst Case der
schlimmste Fall wäre ja wenn für Joe
Biden wenn beide Häuser verloren gingen
also eine Mehrheiten hätten
nach einer solchen zweifachen Niederlage
hat er dann überhaupt keinen Spielraum
mehr oder kann er nach der
amerikanischen Verfassung doch noch
Politik gestalten naja die Frage ist wie
nachhaltig er Politik gestalten kann er
hat natürlich immer die Möglichkeit mit
präsidialen erlassen bestimmte Dinge
durchzusetzen er kann sein Veto einlegen
also gewissen kleinen
Gestaltungsspielraum später noch aber
vor allem innenpolitisch wird er
eindeutig eingeschränkt sein und gerade
wenn das Repräsentantenhaus an die
Republikaner gehen sollte und sie das
wahr machen dass sie möglicherweise ein
impeachment Amtsenthebungsverfahren
gegen ihn einleiten wollen dass Sie
verschiedene andere
Untersuchungsausschüsse einrichten
wollen dann wird allein das
Regierungshandeln dadurch schon sehr
blockiert werden also ich denke viel
wird er dann nicht mehr machen können
außenpolitisch wird er möglicherweise
weiter so agieren wie wir das im Moment
von ihm erleben mit der Einschränkung
dass wir nicht genau wissen ob er
Ukraine Hilfen noch durch ein Kongress
bringen wird also man braucht allerdings
unsere dazu sagen ja eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit im Kongress um Joe Biden
vorzeitig nach Delaware zurückzuschicken
Frau Brockschmidt
Vito kann er noch einliegen aber man
kann ja nur gegen etwas ein Veto
einlegen nicht für etwas das heißt also
das Programm oder die die Programmpunkte
die er vor zwei Jahren angekündigt hat
die ja noch nicht durchgebracht hat oder
noch nicht verwirklichen konnte die
fallen jetzt alle unter den Tisch
also in dem Fall dass die Demokraten
senat- und Repräsentantenhaus verlieren
dann hat beiden eben wirklich kaum
eigene gestalterische Möglichkeiten mehr
der exekutivverordnung die wurden ja
gerade schon angesprochen das ist noch
möglich aber angesichts der aktuellen
Besetzung auch das Obersten Gerichtshofs
ist es dann auch fraglich wie lange
solche exekutivverordnung überhaupt noch
stehen bleiben würden also wenn hier
wirklich beides verloren geht beide kann
man das Kongresses was ja typisch wäre
eigentlich für eine mitteilen weil für
die Partei die den Präsidenten stellt
dann werden die nächsten zwei Jahre
extrem schwierig für breiten und das
wird ja vor allen Dingen auch deswegen
passieren weil eben ein Teil wir haben
es ja schon gehört hier in der Sendung
der neuen republikanischen Abgeordneten
den Parlamentarismus ja gerade zu
verachten und auch ein bisschen auf
unsere Interessen bei dieser Wahl sehen
das wird er mit großer Aufmerksamkeit in
Deutschland verfolgt weil mittelbar
betrifft uns das auch wir werden in
Zukunft wahrscheinlich einen häufiger
hören Kevin McCarthy das ist der
bisherige minderheitenführer im
Repräsentantenhaus nach einer Übernahme
durch die Republikaner ist er der
sogenannte mehrheitsführer und der hat
schon angekündigt das was uns den
meisten Moment beschäftigt auch unsere
transatlantischen Verhältnis ist ja der
Krieg gegen die Ukraine da würde der
US-Kongress der ja das Budgetrecht hat
keine wirklich keinen Blankoscheck mehr
auch einfach mal so gesagt um da den
Wahlkampf so ein bisschen anzuheizen und
den Präsidenten der ja ganz anders denkt
da in die in Bedrängnis zu bringen oder
muss man das ernst nehmen was er gesagt
hat also ich glaube muss man schon ernst
nehmen weil er
steht über eine eine Partei über eine
Gruppe im Abgeordnetenhaus die auch
gewissen massengespalten ist dann es
gibt eine Mehrheit eine deutliche
Mehrheit der Republikaner in dem Senats
und und auch eine Mehrheit der
Republikaner die im Abgeordnetenhaus
sind die für die Ukraine hinter die
Ukraine stehen allerdings gibt es auch
eine sehr aktivistischen Flügel
lagerflügel innerhalb der europäischen
Partei vor allem Abgeordnetenhaus die
sagen jetzt reicht mit der Ukraine wir
mussten jetzt zu Hause investieren das
ist so die isolationalistische Flügel
das ist was Donald Trump ein bisschen
vertritt auch und die würden auch
versuchen ihm in diese Ecke zu drücken
das man mehr Übersicht hat mehr
Anhörungen hat weniger Geld für die
Ukraine ausgibt und ich glaube der muss
auf diese Leute aufmerksam sein den
seine Mehrheit ist damit abhängig das
heißt die Transatlantiker haben nichts
mehr zu lachen ja für die wird es auf
jeden Fall schwieriger und
ich sehe das genauso bei den
Republikanern und man muss ja auch sehen
was hat also jetzt wird oft gesagt naja
beiden wird seine Außenpolitik ja
weitermachen weil er ist ja so ein
Transatlantiker aber wenn wir jetzt in
zwei Jahren Wahlen haben oder bis zwei
Jahre bis zu den Wahlen hin dann werden
da aus meiner Sicht auch Dynamiken
entstehen in einem Wahlkampf die auch
dazu führen dass beiden nicht mehr
realistisch transatlantisch sein kann
man sieht es ja schon längst an seiner
Wirtschaftspolitik die ja schon viel
mehr America first ist also es jemals
vor Trump war und ich gehe davon aus
dass das dann auch in der Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik so kommen wird und
dass ich Deutschland auf einstellen wird
so oder so dass man sich nicht mehr so
hinter den Amerikanern verstecken können
wird wie bisher nur Ukraine Krieg und es
war bis jetzt extrem so auch wenn die
Bundesregierung das seit Monaten
abstreitet und nur damit zu sagen nicht
ja die Ukraine Politik ist wie
parteiisch aber die Art und Weise wie
die beiden das macht ist nicht unbedingt
wie parteiisch und ich glaube wir würden
schon Anhörungen sehen zu die
Beziehungen zwischen Handarbeiten und
die Ukraine vor allem barisma diese
Version Arbeiten genau und auch seine
seine Interessen und seine Beziehung in
China und was das bedeutet vor
Korruption also es wird schon
politisierte
manchmal vergisst man ja dass das
impeachment auf dass wir so gebannt
geschaut haben vor wenigen Jahren nur im
Kern um das Thema Ukraine gegen und
sozusagen da
gespielt wurde eigentlich von von Trump
auch mit einer Solidarität oder die
sondern mit der Solidarität mit der
Ukraine das war sehr kompliziert alles
damals aber im Kern ging es darum dass
die Ukraine nur ein Spielball war für
für innenpolitische Grabenkämpfe America
first auch in der Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik Frau Brock Schmidt
das heißt also muss man damit rechnen
wir reden jetzt noch von dem
zweiten Durchgang der beiden
Präsidentschaft aber möglicherweise mit
einem gegnerischen mit einer
gegnerischen Mehrheit im Kongress muss
man dann mit rechnen dass die USA dann
auch in der außensicherheitspolitik mehr
oder minder schon wie Trump ohne
Rücksicht auf die Nato-Partner agieren
wird
also ich denke nicht dass es eine
gleiche der Außenpolitik wäre wie das
unter Trump der Fall sein würde aber man
muss trotzdem glaube ich damit rechnen
das sollten jetzt eben wirklich beide
kann man verloren gehen dass sich dann
die Prioritäten der beiden Regierung
durchaus auch verschieben das hat man ja
auch bei Obama nach den verlorenen
mütterns gesehen dass man sich stärker
nach innen konzentriert hat dass man
stärker versucht hat sich auf die
Innenpolitik zu konzentrieren in dem
Versuch überhaupt noch irgendetwas an
der eigenen Agenda zu realisieren auch
wenn das natürlich fast unmöglich sein
wird also ich glaube man muss sich
darauf einstellen dass
hier sich das transatlantische Klima
vielleicht doch etwas abkühlt muss man
denn oder kann es möglicherweise sein
dass sich die USA vollkommen aus der
Ukraine Unterstützung zurückziehen
dass wir letztendlich in Europa allein
gegen Putin stehen also so lange beiden
Präsident ist glaube ich das ehrlich
gesagt nicht also ich denke es wird
möglicherweise Abkühlen also da stimme
ich Annika bruckschmidt absolut zu weil
Amerika sich stärker auf sich selbst
konzentrieren wird nach dieser Wahl
unabhängig davon wie es jetzt ausgeht
sie gehen dann einfach auch schon auf
den nächsten Präsidentschaftswahlkampf
zu das darf man nicht außer Acht lassen
das beginnt ja in den USA immer sehr
frühzeitig von daher denke ich wenn sie
sich nicht mehr so stark Richtung Europa
transatlantisch ausrichten aber ich
denke auf beiden in der Hinsicht kann
man sich weiterhin verlassen er wird
sich eher das stimme ich Ihnen zu
wirtschaftspolitisch distanzieren also
da glaube ich da stehen etwas harter
Zeit schon angefangen mit der
bevorzugten amerikanischen Produkte
müssen Inflation Act eine Frage ist
natürlich zwei Jahre bis zur Wahl ja wir
haben uns jetzt mit geopolitischen
Verwerfungen zu tun die die größten sind
seit Jahrzehnten ist es sozusagen für
die für die Bundesregierung
strategisch betrachtet in irgendeiner
Form sinnvoll zu gucken was jetzt in
diesen zwei Jahren ob beiden noch so ein
bisschen hält oder nicht oder muss man
denn nicht viel mehr
strategisch viel weiter nach vorne
blicken und für alle Eventualitäten
sichersten und da schaut es auch mal aus
meiner Sicht einfach im Moment noch so
aus dass man überhaupt nicht sagen kann
ob Deutschland die diese zeitenwände ob
Europa diese ganzen großen Bekenntnisse
zu mehr Autonomie in irgendeiner Form
umsetzen wird die Frage noch mal die ich
gerade an Frau puppenmaier gestellt habe
Europa allein gegen Putin aber dann nach
einer Präsidentschaftswahl die
möglicherweise einen Republikaner oder
eine Republikanerin ins Weiße Haus
bringt ich sehe es wie verbuckmayer ich
glaube nicht dass jetzt in den nächsten
zwei Jahren wenn ich mal jetzt
genau das kann sein und und darauf muss
ich die deutsche Außenpolitik einstellen
und nicht jetzt irgendwie auf diese zwei
Jahre gucken darf ich zwei Fakten oder
zwei Elemente hier reinbringen das erste
ist
kein Präsidentin der US-Geschichte in
den letzten in meinem Leben war so
Atlantik orientiert wie Joe Biden der
hat wirklich in dieser Beziehung vor
allem mit der EU wirklich investiert und
der Grund ist nicht nur um wiedergut zu
machen von der tomzeit sondern zu sagen
wir glauben in diese Beziehung weil es
lohnt uns auch der redet immer von
Außenpolitik für der mittleren Klasse
und es ist es muss sich lohnen auch in
in sich der Zeitenwende dass Europa ein
bisschen mehr Verantwortung für die
Sicherheit Europas aufnimmt und ich
glaube das gibt eine breite Konsens es
ist nicht nur dass die USA nach innen
schaut sondern auch nach indompezifik
also die das was man sieht wirklich in
auch in dieser Wahlkampf als als
politisches Thema vielleicht
gleichgestellt wie Ukraine ist China und
in Zukunft wird die tektonische Richtung
der USA in Richtung in doppelzifik und
China gehen und man denkt die
demokratische Säule diese Beziehung in
Europa ist eben Europa selbst
schon so gewesen diese Ankündigung noch
nicht so stark wie das sich
möglicherweise jetzt gerade anbahnt also
ich glaube das für beiden es unglaublich
wichtig war als Olaf Scholz diese Rede
gehalten hat mit der Zeitenwende weil er
das im Prinzip auch im Land brauchte
dass seine transatlantische Politik
sozusagen weiterhin im Land unterstützt
wurde das tatsächlich etwas kam von
Deutschland von Europa dass man ihm auch
was gegeben hat weil er war ja durchaus
sehr in der Kritik auch teilweise auch
aus der Demokratischen Partei dass er im
Prinzip sich immer so weit nach
Deutschland ausgerichtet hat und nach
Europa und die haben immer gesagt ja
aber guckt euch das doch an die machen
Nord Stream die gucken nach Russland und
so warum unterstützt ihr die überhaupt
also beiden war das selber auch unter
einem großen Druck in den USA und
deswegen war für ihn das sehr wichtig
dass Deutschland dass seine Politik
geändert hat ich finde es eine ziemlich
interessanten Gedanken
ich glaube und das ist ihr Stichwort von
der eben ich glaube Langfristigkeit ist
ganz ganz wichtig was die deutsche
Beziehung zu den USA angeht und da habe
ich bisher noch das Gefühl dass in der
deutschen Außenpolitik noch nicht so
richtig angekommen ist dass dieses Land
dass die Demokratie in diesem Land
wirklich im Abgrund steht und das selbst
sollte jetzt ein Wunder geschehen und
sollten die Demokraten wieder alle
Umfragen doch noch beide Kammern des
Kongresses halten was ich nicht glaube
aber selbst sollte das passieren dann
wäre das auch weiterhin nur ein ein
Aufschub es wäre quasi noch mal zwei
Jahre Zeit um quasi noch Schlimmeres zu
verhindern also ein ähnlicher Effekt wie
bei beiden zwei nun müssten wir damit
rechnen dass es dass es deutlich
schlimmer kommt für die Demokratie und
ich glaube wir dürfen nicht davon
ausgehen dass sich diese republikanische
Partei in der nächsten Zeit irgendwie
von ihrer Radikalisierung entfernt und
das würde ich auch so sehen und eine
gesamten Gedanken finde ich ja weil sie
vorhin sagen die Zeitenwende Rede war
wichtig für beiden das würde ich voll
unterschreiben und würde sogar so weit
gehen zu sagen Deutschland kann
eigentlich nichts
kann eigentlich selber ein aktiven
Beitrag dazu leisten eine
Präsidentschaft Trump zu verhindern
indem man weiter auf diesem Weg der
Zeiten wenn die geht und weiter mehr
Verantwortung übernimmt weil es dann
eben schwieriger wird für die America
first-fraktion
auf die auf die transatlantica zu zeigen
und zu sagen ihr ihr lauft nur den
Europäern das glauben Sie denn dass es
die durchschnittliche amerikanische
Wählerschaft registriert wenn wir jetzt
mehr Verantwortung übernehmen mehr
Finanzhilfen für die Ukraine mehr
Militärhilfe
gewähren dass sie sagen naja gut jetzt
brauchen wir den den Trump oder die
tramisten nicht mehr weil die Deutschen
haben begriffen sind das wird der
durchschnittliche Wähler vielleicht
nicht jetzt weil er jeden Tag eine tanzt
von hinten bis vorne durchliest sehen
aber die Frage ist ja gibt man den
franzisten der Angriffsfläche und
Deutschland Bashing war ja ein
essentieller Punkt des trampismus und es
wird es wieder seinem Wahlkampf und wenn
man sich so verhält wie Deutschland
bisher nach der Zeiten wenn der Rede ich
sehe die Rede als guten Punkt und sehe
aber danach sehr sehr wenig von
deutscher Seite wird man diese Flanke
wieder offen haben Frau Brockschmidt
ja ich glaube man darf dazu noch ganz
kurz ich glaube man darf allerdings
nicht in den Fehler machen davon
auszugehen dass die die magerfraktion
quasi die in der republikanischen Partei
ein
dass die ja dass die in good face
argumentieren also ich sag mal so die
Faktenlage ist relativ irrelevant dafür
dass der narrative und Erzählungen die
sie verbreiten funktionieren also
deswegen glaube ich
ist es mit Sicherheit vielleicht gut für
die transatlantischen Beziehungen unter
einem Präsidenten breiten wenn
Deutschland etwas aktiver wird aber ich
glaube nicht dass das einen großen
Einfluss auf die America first Cloud hat
roblox ich würde gerne was sie gerade
gesagt haben von der Demokratie im
Abgrund noch mal aufnehmen wenn es jetzt
dazu kommt dass diese von Donald Trump
angekündigte rote Welle
gebrochen die USA flute dann wird ja
erst mal abgerechnet vor allen Dingen
über diese sogenannte gestohlene Wahl
die ja keine war aber es
offensichtlicher mindestens die Hälfte
der republikanischen Wähler das immer
noch so sehen dass das eine gestohlene
Wahl war und Wahlbetrug könnte es denn
sein auch nach dem was sie jetzt in USA
gerade während des Wahlkampf erlebt
haben dass das was wir vom 6 Januar noch
mit Schrecken in Erinnerung haben dieser
Sturm auf eine demokratische Institution
dass ich das an verschiedenen Stellen in
USA jetzt wiederholen könnte
ich denke nicht unbedingt in einem
zweiten Sturm aus Kapitol oder auf eine
andere dieser Institution ich glaube
aber dass wir jetzt allein schon in den
letzten Wochen im Wahlkampf ja gesehen
haben dass politische Gewalt in den USA
von rechts enorm an Bedeutung gewonnen
hat wir haben republikanische
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten die sich
teilweise offen für den
einsatzpolitischer Gewalt aussprechen
und wir müssen glaube ich auch uns daran
erinnern ist wenn ja hier nicht nur
Abgeordnete und Senatoren gewählt
sondern auch Gouverneure und auch lokale
Positionen wie secretaries of state also
Positionen in denen die Leute die
behaupten die letzte Wahl sei gestohlen
worden in der Lage wären den Ausgang von
Wahlen in der Zukunft zu manipulieren
das ist also der Plan der Plan ist
weniger jetzt also nochmal das Kapitol
zu stürmen sondern also einen eine Art
soften Staatsstreich über sollten
juristische Wege zu ermöglichen und die
Mehrheit der fast 300 nominierten
electiondinners unter Republik wird
wahrscheinlich ihre Rennen gewinnen 171
davon treten in fest republikanischen
sitzen an und bei ganzen 48 wird das
Rennen knapp also auf die Dauer muss man
damit rechnen dass hier von innen
versucht wird die Demokratie zu
zerstören also elektrischen nochmal
erklären das sind diejenigen die die
Wahl zur beiden 2020 nach wie vor nicht
anerkennen
es gab ja auch immer wieder den Spruch
von mehreren Leuten von mehreren
Kandidaten dass sie im Prinzip eine Wahl
nur anerkennen wenn sie selber gewinnen
ja ich meine das ist einfach etwas und
das macht jetzt schon sehr schwierig
einen wichtigen wichtige Funktionen
genannt nämlich den Secretary of State
das ist so etwas wie der Innenminister
oder Innenministerin eines
US-Bundesstaates in dieser diese die
sind diejenige nein nein ja genau die in
den Ländern in den Staaten die Wahl
zertifizieren
letzten 2024 dann auch bei einem klaren
Wahlergebnis zu Gründer Demokraten sagen
nö stimmt nicht waren die Republikaner
was ja aber das mussten sie nachgehen
diese sie haben ganz genau einen sehr
gute Punkt gemacht mit der
Institutionalisierung der große Lüge
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
und das selbst kommt weiter im
Abgeordnetenhaus in vielen Ländern 51%
der
republikane die auf dem Wahlzettel sind
unterstützen entweder sind weil Leugner
oder haben es im Zweifel gesetzt man
muss das auch sagen das ist auch eine
Taktik um die Hardcore mager Stammwähler
auf ihre Seite zu halten
aber ich glaube es gibt immer noch nach
wie vor gut genug Institutionen
umzusichern dass diese Wahl und Zukünfte
globale durchgeführt werden
weil es kann jetzt noch was anderes
passieren was ja auch 2020/21 auch
passiert ist es ja nicht nur Trump hat
nicht nur versucht Einfluss zu nehmen
auf die Zertifizierung sondern neben der
roten Welle gibt es ja möglicherweise
auch eine Welle eine Flut von Klagen vor
Gerichten
auch um den Wahlausgang die Auszählung
und die Zertifizierung zu verzögern das
ist ja über mehrere Wochen hat sich das
ja hingezogen diese Gefahr dann ist sie
nicht nur gegeben sondern für die
möglicherweise noch bedrohlicher werden
für die Demokratie ich glaube es ist
kein Gefahr das ist eine Tatsache es
wird dazu kommen also eines was wir
jetzt die Erwartungen setzen müssen ist
dass wir morgen keine
eindeutige Ergebnis haben würden sondern
das wird sich ziehen wochenlang
vielleicht monatelang sogar die Senats
wenn in Georgia konnte zu einem run off
gehen die bis Januar führt was sehr
gefährlich ist für die Demokratie in den
USA ist diese Steigerung an politische
Gewalt und was man sieht ist die
bedrohungsbriefe die glaubwürdige
Bedrohungen im Kongress haben sich
verzehnfacht von auf 10.000 und das ist
muss man ehrlich sagen nicht nur Rex
Extremisten das ist so 35 bis 40 Prozent
dann gibt es fünf so Richtung 15 Prozent
die von Linksextremisten kommen zum
Beispiel gibt wurde angegriffen von
Linksextremisten auch
carvenor wurde bedroht von seinem von
seinem Haus aber die meisten sind
einfach verrückte die durch die
politische Umlage einfach polyetisiert
sind und Sie schaffen würden Angst an
der Stelle bei also wenn man sich
anguckt das Wahlhelferinnen und
Wahlhelfer wirklich bedroht werden Leute
die einfach ehrenamtlich helfen die Wahl
durchzuführen wirklich mit ihrem Leben
bedroht werden Angst haben müssen viele
haben dann gesagt dann mache ich diesen
Job nicht mehr und es gab einen
richtigen Mangel an Wahlhelferinnen und
Wahlhelfern also wo man einfach wirklich
ein Klima der Angst hat was finde ich
nicht gut ist für Demokratie roblox mit
und ich glaube da muss man noch mal
betonen dass ja also Steve skelease
wurde ja es war mit Republikaner der
angeschossen wurde es gibt natürlich
auch Akte linker politischer Gewalt aber
der große Unterschied ist und ich glaube
da darf man wirklich jetzt keinen beide
Seiten sind quasi gleich draus machen
ist das
Republikaner gewählte Republikaner seit
Jahren
Demokraten dämonisieren Demokraten nicht
als politischen Gegner mit dem man sich
eben streitet oder dem man gegen
jemanden versucht zu gewinnen sehen
sondern gegen eine eine zutiefst
unangemerikanische Gruppierungen die
versucht das Land zu zerstören also mit
denen überhaupt kein Diskurs möglich ist
die mit dem Teufel im Bunde sind die
Kinder Blut trinken
dann muss man sich über dieses
klimapolitische Gewalt nicht wundern
also das kommt auch wenn es Einzeltaten
von links gibt klar aber
allgemeine Klima was von rechts Gewalt
legitimiert von höchster Stelle das
kommt nur von einer Seite
ja
ich bin jetzt sicher hier nicht der
der größte Amerika Experte soll und
kennen das Land weniger gut als viele
von ihnen aber trotzdem diese diese
Dämonisierung und dieses dieses
apodiktische und die dieses
katastropische das durchkommt bis hin zu
der Aussage von ihnen dass sie sagen es
ist eigentlich egal was man macht es
geht ihnen nicht mehr um Fakten sondern
dass nur eine Bande durchgeknallte Leute
die das Land ruinieren so quasi das
finde ich jetzt einfach ich sag nicht
das ist eine sozusagen
es gibt in diesem Laden von 320
Millionen keine Basis mehr um es zu
retten nein nein nein nein das ist ja
das ist ja noch mal eine ganz andere
Frage ich glaube wir müssen auf jeden
Fall unterscheiden zwischen
republikanischen Politikern
republikanischen Politikern im gewählten
Positionen und republikanischen Wählern
ich würde auf keinen Fall sagen dass die
Mehrheit der republikanischen Wähler
voll dabei ist jetzt die Demokratie zu
schaffen es gibt ja auch im Land keine
zahlenmäßige Mehrheit dafür hier jetzt
irgendwie ein totalitären Staat
einzuführen das wäre ja quatsch das ist
zu behaupten das Problem ist dass sich
eine eine der beiden großen beiden
Parteien und das ist eben eindeutig
entschlossen hat wenn es Sie sich
entscheiden muss zwischen macht Erhalt
und Demokratie dass sie dann lieber als
Minderheit ihren Willen durchsetzen und
dann muss die Demokratie eben weg und
ich glaube das lässt sich aufgrund der
Faktenlage nicht abstreiten Geiger was
bedeutet das eigentlich für das ganz
grundsätzlich für das transatlantische
Verhältnis in Zukunft wenn Demokratie
und Rechtsstaatlichkeit in den USA auf
wackeligen Füßen stehen macht sich das
dann auch bemerkbar in den
außenpolitischen Beziehungen
Verlässlichkeit
Absprachen Verträge ja natürlich
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen natürlich
also sozusagen ich
habe 2016 ist noch nicht als die
Katastrophe als die es viele deutsche
Medien gesehen haben gesehen dass Donald
Trump gewählt wurde sondern habe es auch
gesehen als eine Chance als eine Chance
für eine Entwicklung
die
so nicht gekommen ist und also eine
Entwicklung zum Beispiel auch ein
transatlantischen Verhältnis
das bestimmte Themen auf den Tisch
kommen zum Beispiel der ehemalige
US-Botschafter in Deutschland schon
Kornblumen hat damals gesagt Donald
Trump ist Europas letzte Chance was er
damit sagen wollte ist Donald Trump ist
die Chance dass man endlich die Warnung
oder dass man endlich das wahrnimmt was
die Amerikaner immer schon sagen gebt
mir für eure Sicherheit aus tut mehr für
die NATO tut einfach mehr und seid nicht
hüttbettfahrer unseres
schutzversprechens was für 70 Jahre lang
waren und was haben wir gemacht gar
nichts das sieht man jetzt wir sind
jetzt
fünf Jahre nach der Wahl von Donald
Trump oder sechs Jahre nach der Wahl von
Donald Trump völlig überrascht worden
von Ukraine Krieg und
2024 würde ich es schon auch für eine
Katastrophe erhalten wenn Trump wieder
gewählt wurde in dieser labilen Weltlage
weiß ich nicht wie weder das
transatlantische Verhältnis noch sonst
die die Sicherheitsarchitektur der Welt
des aushalten soll er lassen es bevor
wir diese Frage nochmal weiterverfolgen
was wird denn aus diesem
Untersuchungsausschuss im Kongress was
die Vorgänge des 6 Januar angeht wird
der jetzt von der Mehrheit der
Republikaner möglicherweise
liquidiert musste muss Trump eine
Anklage nicht mehr fürchten die zwar
nicht der Kongress erhebt sondern der
Justizminister in dem Moment wo die
Republikaner die Mehrheit haben wird der
Untersuchungsausschuss beendet werden
die Arbeit also davon bin ich absolute
überzeugt eine Anklage zu erleben
Ex-Präsident nicht wieder im Amt aber
noch als Ex Präsident ist weitgehend
gebannt für ihn also die aber nicht es
gibt ja wirtschaftliche Sachen also das
ist nicht eindeutig gebannt also ich
könnte mir durchaus vorstellen dass
Donald Trump was ganz anderes zum
Verhängnis wird nicht das was politisch
sich abgespielt hat mit dem Sturm aufs
Kapitol sondern das möglicherweise seine
Geschäftsbeziehungen für ihn Problem
werden also daran wird ja nach wie vor
recherchiert und ja und es gibt sehr
ernsthaft und das ist das ist das Gute
an Föderalismus oder es gibt auch
schlechte Sachen an federalismus in den
USA und auch in Deutschland aber das ist
eine Labor der Demokratie sagen wir mal
und es gibt auch andere unabhängige
Justizsysteme und wir haben Klagen in
Georgia zum Beispiel um seine versucht
das die Wahl zu manipulieren auch in New
York zum Beispiel und die sind sehr
ernsthaft und die andere Frage ist wird
die Justiz das Justizministerium der USA
von Joe Biden diese Beweise die
abgegeben wurden vom
untersuchungsausschluss genau würden sie
aufgenommen von mercuryland das ist auch
eine große Frage und mit dem Finanzamt
steht er ja möglicherweise auch auf
Kriegsfuß Frau Brockschmidt
ja also Donald Trump hat eine ganze
literei an an möglichen Prozessen die
ihm die im Drohnen und teilweise laufen
ja auch schon wirklich ernst zu nehmende
Ermittlungen deswegen würde ich sagen
also man kann auf jeden Fall damit
rechnen dass dieser
Untersuchungsausschuss zum sechsten
Januar eingestampft wird sobald
Republikaner die Mehrheit haben das
haben sie ja schon angekündigt das ist
also glaube ich da muss man gar nicht
mehr drüber spekulieren das ist schon
recht eindeutig
das hat glaube ich auf Mary Garland
jetzt keine auf den Justizminister
keine große
Auswirkungen aber man muss trotzdem
sagen also Trump droht eine Vielzahl an
juristischen Dingen war es natürlich für
ihn noch mehr Ansporn ist erneut zu
kandidieren weil er braucht diese
weiteren vier Jahre Immunität wird er
das tun wird er antreten oder was ist
die Voraussetzung dafür dass wir wissen
das was wir gestern selber gesagt hatte
und dass wir auf dem 15 November schauen
sollten weil es wird eine sehr wichtige
Ankündigung geben die uns gefallen wird
wenn die Republikaner nicht ganz so toll
abschneiden wie sie jetzt alle hoffen
kann das dann eine Auswirkung auf diese
Frage haben ich könnte es mir vorstellen
dass er versucht zu sagen ja deswegen
bin ich gekommen um die Partei zu retten
also er hat eine narrative in beide
Richtungen wenn die Republikaner wie
erwartet eine rot zu einer rote Welle
wenn es dazu kommt dann sagt er der
eigentliche Grund dafür war ich weil ich
habe mehr oder weniger beinahe gesagt
ich kandidiere und das liegt an mir und
wenn sie verlieren dann sagt er warum
weil ich nicht vorher angekündigt habe
dass ich kandidiere also er ist auf
jeden Fall nie der Verlierer davon
glaube ich kann man aus also er hat ja
keine besonders guten persönlichen Werte
in den USA könnt ihr das ein weiterer
Grund sein dass manche in der
republikanischen Partei vielleicht sogar
dran Pisten also eigentlich die ihn als
Vorbild sehen sagen also junge du hast
deine Verdienste gehabt für uns aber die
Gefahr ist bewusst dass du 2024 mit
diesen imageschwerten scheiters das
heißt da käme dann auch ein
Gegenkandidat oder Kandidatinnen aus der
eigenen republikanischen Partei in Frage
also im Moment ist es richtig er hat
keine sonderlich guten Werte aufs ganze
Land gesehen aber er hat einfach einen
großen Teil in der republikanischen
Basis hinter sich und im Moment kann
sich keiner vorstellen von den
republikanischen möchtegern-kandidaten
dass sie etwas gewinnen könnten gegen
Trump sie können es nur wenn Trump
selber sagt dass das nicht macht also so
im Moment ist seinen Rückhalt in der
Basis nach wie vor so groß dass man
gegen ihn dann nicht also ein besonderes
von Florida zum Beispiel kann nicht
bestehen gegen Donald Trump im Moment
wenn er sagt ich ich mache es jetzt dann
werden sich die Truppen sammeln bin ich
im Moment relativ überzeugt und werden
nicht gegen ihn sich positionieren man
hat ja gesehen vor diesen Wahlen was den
Leuten passiert die sich gegen ihn
gestellt hat entweder sie sind selber
gegangen und sind nicht mehr angetreten
oder Sie haben bereits in den Vorwahlen
ihre Posten verloren oder sie wurden
bedroht und haben dann aufgegeben also
sich gegen Donald Trump zu stellen in
der momentanen Situation bedeutet
eigentlich fast das politische Ende also
kein Königsmörder Frau Brock Schmidt in
der republikanischen Partei in Sicht
jetzt in Bezug auf die Wahl 2024
das denke ich nicht also ich glaube zum
Beispiel dass so jemand wie round the
sentes Florida der ja in den Umfragen
quasi und nur unter der republikanischen
Wählern die eindeutige Nummer 2 ist aber
eben immer noch hinter Trump liegt er
ist ja auch noch relativ jung das heißt
ich glaube er würde auf keinen Fall den
Fehler machen jetzt in eine
Kampfkandidatur gegen Donald Trump zu
gehen ich glaube eher dass er dann
vielleicht nicht auf das Amt des
Vizepräsidenten
schielen würde um sich so eben noch
weitere nationale Bekanntheit zu
erlangen aber ich glaube ich sehe das
genauso also wenn Trump ankündigt ich
mache das dann dann ist er der Kandidat
wir haben ja auch jetzt gesehen im
Vorlauf zu den biturms wie präsent er im
Wahlkampf ist sein indoorsment ist also
seiner seine Zustimmung zu einem
Kandidaten ist unter der Basis
wahnsinnig viel wert weshalb ja auch
zahlreiche oder es hat fast alle
republikanischen Kandidaten die
irgendwie Aussicht auf kam sich
natürlich auch um dieses bemüht haben
und das könnte eines der Gründe sein
warum die Demokraten den Senat erhalten
weil jemand hat mit beconnor der
republikanische Führer eben im Senat
gefragt was ist das Problem warum könnte
es sein dass die homikaner verlieren und
er hat gesagt Kandidaten Qualität und
der meinte dann mit der republikanische
Kandidat in Pennsylvanien dr Earth der
europäischen republikanische Kandidat in
Georgia und ja also Trump hat schon
interessante Leute celebrities und so
ausgewählt für seine Wahl aber wichtig
bei bei Trump ein guter indizio ist noch
ein Politiker Ted Cruise der separatur
aus aus Texas hat gesagt der sind
erzkonservative auch sehr ambitionierte
hat explizit gesagt wenn Trump
kandidiert kandidiere ich nicht
und der macht es nur weil er weiß dass
das Trump wahrscheinlich das macht und
jeder wird ihm den breit den Weg geben
freigeben zu kandidieren
wir sollten vielleicht noch mal auf die
Frage die wir morgen allerdings etwas
mit etwas mehr Erkenntnissen und
Ergebnissen diskutieren können warum es
möglicherweise für die Demokraten schief
gegangen ist wie konnte man sich im
Wahlkampf eigentlich so verschätzen
auf Themen zu setzen die offenbar für
die Amerikaner jetzt oder
Amerikanerinnen bei der Wahl keine so
große Rolle spielen man hat sich auf das
Abtreibungsrecht unterstützt in
Wirklichkeit geht es ja vor allen Dingen
um die Gefahr einer Rezession die
Inflation die in den USA sehr stark
spürbar ist vor allem einen Bereich die
Amerikaner außerordentlich empfindlich
sind nämlich an der Tankstelle
wie ist das denn welche
Wahlkampfstrategen haben die Demokraten
eigentlich beschäftigt
ich glaube ganz so einfach ist es nicht
weil die Entscheidung beispielsweise auf
den Schutz des abtreibungsrechts zu
setzen so stark und das ist stark in den
Vordergrund zu rücken beruhte ja und
beruht nach wie vor ja auch Umfragen an
der Basis wo eindeutig die Sorge um die
Demokratie in den Top drei Themen legt
und mit Toms werden nun mal vor allem
von der eigenen Basis geworden Leute die
beispielsweise vielleicht ein
Präsidentschaftswahlen wählen gehen aber
die jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig mit Politik involviert sind
die gehen unter Umständen gar nicht
wählen die Wahlbeteiligung ist in
mithelms meistens geringer als im
Präsidentschaftswahlen deswegen war es
schon sinnvoll auf die eigenen Leute zu
gucken jetzt würde ich sagen kam ein
paar unglückliche Dinge zusammen wir
hatten im Sommer ja einerseits den
Schock über dieses Supreme Code Urteil
unter anderem was den Schutz auf
Abtreibung gestrichen hat
gleichzeitig gab es eine kurze Senkung
wieder von Benzinpreisen Inflation gegen
kurzzeitig wieder runter um dann eben
aber wieder anzusteigen das heißt ich
glaube
letzten Endes
sind das eben auch Dinge auf die jetzt
ein demokratischer Präsident auch wenn
sie natürlich angelastet wird relativ
wenig Einfluss hat ein vor allem ein
Präsident der ohnehin extrem unbeliebt
ist das sind grundsätzlich keine guten
Voraussetzungen um in einen mittleren
Wahlkampf zu gehen denen die Partei die
den Präsidenten stellt ohnehin wie
gesagt traditionellerweise mit ganz
wenigen Ausnahmen wo der Präsident eben
sehr beliebt ist verliert wir haben
jetzt über Donald Trump und seine
möglichen griff nach einer erneuteten
Präsidentschaft gesprochen die Frage ist
was eigentlich aus Joe Biden der feiert
in diesem Monat seinen 80 geburtstag
möglicherweise kann er oder will er
nicht mehr antreten das ist jetzt nicht
genau
der kommt da eigentlich in Frage also
ich bin jetzt auch nicht unbedingt der
Dichte US-Experte aber mir ist niemand
eingefallen und aufgefallen die
Vizepräsidenten ist offensichtlich da
ein Ausfall der kommt da eigentlich käme
da in Frage zumindestens jemand den wir
auch kennen oder wird das wie 24 Monate
sind schnell vorbei
das ist schwierig also ich will Kamera
Harris für ihre schwache Performance
jetzt nicht unbedingt zählen Schutz
nehmen aber sie ist Vizepräsidentin es
ist vor allem ein repräsentatives Amtes
darf man nicht vergessen und so beiden
hat auch immer klar gemacht sie soll
zwar ordentlich ihre Meinung sagen aber
bitte hinter verschlossenen Türen also
es wird auch nicht so sehr gewünscht
dass sie wirklich mit einem eigenen
Profil nach draußen geht das ist bei
Vizepräsidenten so es war auch unter
Trump nicht so dass der Vizepräsident
extrem präsent war also das kann man ihr
nicht wirklich Anlassen trotzdem sehe
ich momentan auch nicht unbedingt dass
sie eine gute Präsidentschaftskandidatin
wäre es ist echt schwierig es kommt
nicht so richtig jemand raus als ich
noch in den USA war ist häufiger über
Pete Budgets gesprochen worden der hatte
ja bereits versucht sie ja glaube ich
momentan Verkehrs nee nicht den Text der
jetzige Verkehrsminister der war als
Konkurrent angetreten damals gegen
beiden hat einige wirklich gute Erfolge
damals erzielt da wird gesagt er hat
sein Ministerium guten Griff er macht
gute Sachen das Infrastrukturprogramm
was ja ein Erfolg von beiden ist ist
auch etwas bei dem eher punkten kann ich
weiß es nicht ob er sich möglicherweise
herausarbeiten kann dass
ehrenpotentieller Kandidat wäre es ist
aber auch nicht ausgeschlossen dass Joe
Biden tatsächlich noch mal eine
Kandidatur versucht ja egal wie alt er
ist gleich am Ende der Sendung
zum Resümee also ob Trump ob beiden oder
sonst wer 20024 Präsident wird für uns
wird es auf jeden Fall ungemütlicher auf
jeden Fall auf jeden Fall und das
sollten wir uns jetzt schon darauf
einstellen es ist ja auch schon ziemlich
ungemütlich geworden für uns in
Deutschland mit dem Ukraine kriegen mit
dem was unser Außenpolitik der letzten
zehn Jahre wohin die geführt hat und ich
glaube es wäre höchste Zeit zu erkennen
dass es 2024 noch ungemütlicher werden
könnte dann wenn du noch 24 Monate Zeit
und wir warten jetzt erstmal auf die
Ergebnisse von heute Nacht ich bedanke
mich bei Claudia Buckenmaier bei Annika
Brockschmidt live zugeschaltet aus
Washington bei Klaus Geiger und bei
Tyson Barker Liebe Zuschauerinnen und
liebe Zuschauer morgen in der Phoenix
Runde nach den Kongresswahlen kommt
Trump zurück wir schließen also nahtlos
an die heutige Sendung an und vielleicht
können wir da schon einiges beantworten
zu dieser Frage jetzt der Tag mit Hans
Werner fitkau es geht um die returm
elections die Zwischenwahlen in den USA
aber nicht nur in der nächsten Stunde
sondern bis morgen früh Phoenix und
unterbrochen zu den Kongresswahlen in
den USA live aus den USA ja schalten
auch amerikanische Fernsehprogramme auf
wenn Sie Zeit und Lust und entsprechend
Kraft haben bleiben sie bis morgen früh
bei uns
[Musik]